so Buster raw is a premium Bluetooth
portable speaker what really surprised
many people including myself is the
awesome audio that you can get out from
a small box like this The Sound Blaster
is a speaker with a unique orientation
it has subwoofer driver pointing
outwards to travel drivers pointing
forward and two radiators drivers
pointing sideways so if you're blasting
music at full volume the speakers do you
remain stable
one of the biggest challenges was how do
we squeeze everything into such a small
box looking at how we can actually make
not just a speaker about intelligent
speaker that she communicates with
people
the greatest functional value of this
product is being small in size yet it
feels the whole room with music
everyone in the team has their own
strength we had a very open environment
it's not about who did what it's more
about like what we did collectively as a
team pushing the best ideas and
expertise forward and so does the raw is
a great example of this approach
president design award has been an event
that put the best of singapore's design
on display as far as showcasing the
designers behind these great books this
send a message to ask that does
high-level creativity in Singapore and
that can be something that we can be
proud of it is also inspiration to all
of us to listen to stories that will
inspire these designers as well as the
journey that they took to get them there
the president's design what has been an
event I pushed the best that Singapore
has to offer in terms of design on
display learn to have fun when you're
coming up with new ideas my advice for
emerging designers is that really love
what you do the trio bars has been
working in the design view for more than
ten years and just believe that one day
you will do great work
this is some duster all design of the
year
Oh